The starting block below
is 16/9 units long.
So this right here
Use the tools to the right
to convert the starting block
into the goal block
that is 1 unit long.
So this right over
here is 1 unit long.
You can see your progress
as the current block.
So how do we convert
this into 1 unit?
Well, one we can start
cutting it into some pieces.
Let's just see what happens.
So if we cut it into
2 pieces, how big
is this red section now?
So if we cut this in
half, a 1/2 times 16/9
this is now going to be 8/9.
If we cut it into 4 pieces,
then this is going to be 4/9.
If we cut it into,
looks like we're
going to have to go all
the way to 16 pieces
to get it into 1/9.
So let's cut this
into 16 pieces.
So now if you take
16/9 and if you
were to cut it into
16 pieces, this
is going to be 1/9
right over here.
So if I have 1/9 and I
want to make it a whole,
how many do I need?
Well, I need 9 of them.
So let's do 2/9, 3/9, 4/9,
5/9, 6/9, 7/9, 8/9, and 9/9.
And let's check our answer.
Let's do a couple more of these.
So the starting block right over
here is 1 and 9/12 units long.
And we're going to use these
tools to convert the block
into a goal block that
is 1 and 8/12 units long.
You can see your progress
as the current block.
So the most obvious
thing to me is
if I were to just convert the
starting block into 12ths.
And then I could replicate, I
could copy those 12ths enough
to get to 1 and 8/12.
So how many times do I
have to cut this in order
to get it into just 1/12?
So 1 and 9/12 is the
same thing as 12/12
plus 9/12, which is 21/12.
So if I cut this into
21 blocks, each of them
are going to be 1/12.
Because this is 21/12
right over here.
So let me cut it into 21.
So right now, I cut
this into 21 blocks.
This was 21/12.
If I cut it, this is 1/21 of
that, so it's going to be 1/12.
So this is 1/12.
And now I just have to
copy it enough times
to get to 1 and 8/12.
And 1 and 8/12 is the same thing
as 12/12 plus 8/12 is 20/12.
So this is 1/12.
If I get 20 of these, then it's
going to be the same length.
So let me do that.
So it's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16,
17, 18, 19, 20.
And we are spot on.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do one more of these.
This is fun.
So this starting block
is 11/8 units long.
We want to convert into a
block that is 1 unit long.
So if I can convert the starting
block into eighths, and the way
that I could make
this into 1/8 is
by essentially
dividing it by 11.
Now I have 11/8 and I divide by
11, I'm only going to have 1/8.
So let me cut into 11 pieces.
So now this is 1/8.
And then if I take this
1/8 and if I replicate it
so I have 8 of them, 8/8
is going to be equal to 1.
So let me do that.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And we got it right.